wie die andere
es war so linus valley state prison ein
hochsicherheitsgefängnis in kalifornien
das ist magdalena job meine schwester
was sie hier zu tun hat und wie sie
hierher kam davon handelt dieser film
[Musik]
unsere familie in den 50er jahren mutter
vater und vier kinder von den mittleren
beiden magdalena und mir soll hier die
rede sein
[Musik]
magdalena oder makler ich sie nannte war
eine mit der konnte man streiche spielen
das bohr bereitliegen
[Musik]
ich soll auf ein wohnmobil achten sagt
sie mir als sie mich in minneapolis
abholen kommt
magdalena ist jetzt amerikanerin sie
lebt seit über 40 jahren in kalifornien
entsprechen selten sehen wir uns
eine fahrt in ihrem wohnmobil quer durch
die vereinigten staaten eine ideale
gelegenheit erinnerungen aufzufrischen
unsere erste etappe hat allerdings ein
trauriges ziel ein besuch an dem
sterbebett magdalena spricht von charles
chuck dem mann der sie über einige
umwege in die vereinigten staaten
gebracht hat
gleich bei ihrer ersten fahrt überqueren
sie den pazifik echte herausforderung
[Musik]
die kleinen elf tage bis 11
sonntag ab 12 j mit dem chance
[Musik]
ich sehe sie nie in dieser zeit bin
anderswo in der welt
aber meine eltern besuchen sie ein paar
mal an exotischen orten
nach fünf jahren erfuhr sie heiraten
charles und magdalena
[Musik]
ja sag mal papa vorhabens kam die idee
zum überlaufen gebracht haben
es ist ein sehr praktisch
bloß einfach
mehrmals über den pazifik zweimal
überqueren sie den atlantik im
mittelmeer hin und her eine intensive
zeit die 70er jahre die große freiheit
magdalena entdeckt ihre liebe zu frauen
sie wird lässt
[Musik]
jetzt müssen aber die selbst stark zu
machen
typisch magdalena scheint mir immer zu
den grenzen ihrer furcht und darüber
hinaus
nach zwölf jahren wird sie sesshaft wenn
sie nicht gerade mit mir unterwegs ist
sie schließt ihr studium ab und beginnt
zu schreiben wie ich ohne dass wir etwas
voneinander wussten kommt ihr erstes
buch 1991 heraus im selben jahr
erscheint doch mein erster krimi wie
früher sprechen wir die ganze nacht über
bücher und schlaf kaum zu denken
am morgen kommt die traurige nachricht
vom krankenlager charles fühlt sich zu
schwach um besucher zu empfangen
[Musik]
ein
juni
japaner santa cruz zu magdalene nach
hause
[Musik]
jens liebchen
mitten in der nacht kommen wir an
doch magdalena kann noch nicht schlafen
das ist wichtig sie die zwölf jahren
was haben diesmal werde bestätigt das
ist einfach verlieren
aber das ist sehr schmerzhaft
hier wohnt sie nun also mit ihrer
partnerin
stolz zeigt sie mir ihre wohnsituation
korrekt dass er das dort
wissenschaftlich und deutsch herz und
das nervöse da geht es ab da ist und
alles perfekt machen
sieben romane von magdalena liegen zwar
strategisch richtig in der wohlstand
säcke aber das hat noch nicht ganz so
geklappt um zu überleben gibt sie
kreative schreibkurse in diesem haus
fand vor 17 jahren als solcher workshop
für frauen statt
die besitzerin kollegin war damals 68
und verliebte sich in magdalena und
seite sind die beiden ein paar
mein mann hat mich nach 42 jahren
verlassen
ich wusste nicht ob ich mir noch eine
andere person steckte aus die rolle die
ich gelernt hatte die der mutter und es
kommt mir immer so vor als ob ich vor 15
jahren neu geboren wurde
als ich meine tiefe zuneigung zum
magdalena entdeckte war mir als 16 und
frisch verliebt und das hatte ich lange
nicht mehr gefühlt
die beiden leben zwar zusammen haben
aber eigene quartiere magdalena genießt
ihr selbstgebautes schlafgemach auch im
winter
du hast alles gut wie wir das akustik
stimmen oder sowie genau ins boot und du
weißt genau das ist ganz gleich wie viel
das es blast und stürmt und regnet nun
gut aber das boot gegen jede hätte es
ist verankert dass ist so erfreut
heute begleitet sie zur arbeit zweimal
pro woche fährt ins gefängnis und
kreatives schreiben zu unterrichten
franken
so wichtig
was erhofft sie sich von ihrem einsatz
30 männer sind bei ihr in der gruppe
magdalena könnte durchaus ihre akten
einsehen dass jeder zweite wird die
gerne mal teil und das konnte natürlich
nicht gemacht mit denen erhalten
wie viele gefängnisse kämpft auch dieses
gegen bestechung und schmuck in die
zellen als iphone kostet solch und solle
im dem kleinlich also wenn du jetzt du
da schaffen und so also sieht ihn ist
möglich als 20 tonnen alle wäre es
natürlich wenn sie der für mich ist das
nicht aber sie sogar laptops die kamera
ins gefängnis zu bringen war nicht
einfach ich musste eine ganze reihe
administrative hürden überwinden bis ich
endlich filmen durfte
roth machte dass die das möglich schätze
wenn man sagt wenn der hund und zum
totalen geboren gehörte springs
[Musik]
vom wächter oben streng bewacht mit
geladenen gewehr treffen die häftlinge
nach und nach hinein
geschätzte 300 haftjahre sind hier
versammelt
[Musik]
mein besuch verzögerten ablauf der
lektion weil wir so spät dran sind
verzichten wir heute auf die nach
korrektur magdalena gibt rezepte gegen
die schreibblockade und anstöße für
interessante geschichten
ich möchte nochmals wiederholen wenn ihr
die perspektive wechselt könnt ihr
spannende geschichten erzählen
es waren einmal drei böse schweinchen
die die jungen wölfe line jagten um
ihnen das fell abzuziehen einmal jagte
wieder so ein schweinchen einen wolf
welten als tornado der gute wolf ihm zu
hilfe kam
dieselbe geschichte aus der perspektive
des bösen wolf natürlich habe ich die
schweinchen gefangen und gebraten wir
hatten ein tolles fest mal mit meinen
freunden zusammen
es gab spanferkel für zwei drei tagen
warst du so hast du etwa eine andere
geschichte gehört terence konnte schon
eine seiner kurzgeschichten
veröffentlichen
berlin kann ganz schön streng seien mit
ihren schülern aber ihre art kommt bei
den gefangenen gut an
magdalena zeigt uns alle möglichen
formen auf zwingt uns aber in keine
richtung
diese freiheit im haus druck weil wir
die beste art des unterrichts zu sein
normalerweise ist der alltag hat und im
knast
mir wird schon mulmig an diesem einen
tag die gefangenen aber sind jahrelang
hier schon beispielsweise ist seit 16
jahren inhaftiert seine strafe dauert 33
jahre vorher könnte ich reisen und hat
es so viel spaß wie nur möglich
jetzt kann ich nicht mehr reisen und
habe keinen spaß mehr
ich hoffe bloß dass ich keine zeit mehr
verschwenden wenn ich rauskomme suche
ich mir jemanden mit dem ich viel zeit
teilen kann und segler mit ihm um die
welt das scheint mir das wichtigste mit
jemandem die zeit zu teilen der sie auch
schätzt
sie bringen mir nahrung dreimal am tag
und machen mich stärker aber ich werde
alt und schwäche sie denken dass ich
einen lebenszweck habe ja ich überlebe
aber leben ist das keins
heute ist der letzte kurs mit dieser
gruppe jeder teilnehmer erhält ein
zertifikat uns alle danken magdalena 2
warten mit einer besonderen überraschung
auf die kür nach der pflicht ein rap und
schließlich noch ein weihnachtslied aus
tonga
[Musik]
seehofer
gg
si
weihnachtslieder im gefängnis das hat
doch mutter schon gemacht
unsere mutter ist 99
sie spielt noch immer jeden tag klavier
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ins gefängnis geht sie nicht mehr außer
wenn wir sie hinfahren
ihr einsatz hat mir wohl mehr eindruck
gemacht
wenn wir schon auf dem vater
erinnerungen sind gehen wir noch ganz an
den anfang zurück
[Musik]
aber nicht mehr auf der bühne auszieht
naja ich selbst
[Musik]